[Music]
hi guys
it's quinn's ideas here if you
appreciate my content consider clicking
the like button
so that the youtube algorithm sees and
circulates my content
thank you guys so much cosmic horror
is a concept that has exploded in
popularity in recent times
but of course this is a type of horror
that great authors have been utilizing
for many decades
more than anyone else h.p lovecraft is
associated with this concept
he is in fact as many of you already
know considered to be the father of
cosmic horror
which is often referred to as
lovecraftian horror
many authors since lovecraft's death
have written stories within his
universe continuing the tradition of
cosmic horror
others like stephen king have adapted
these concepts in their own works
in this video however we will be looking
at cosmic horror from one specific angle
we will be discussing the usage of
cosmic horror in science fiction
specifically i would argue that many of
lovecraft's works are actually science
fiction to begin with
as many of them have ideas traditionally
associated with the science fiction
genre
beings from outer space strange
technology
machines capable of flying through space
for example the story
through the gates of the silver key
which lovecraft co-wrote with edgar
hoffman price
has several elements of science fiction
the story centered around the character
randolph carter
who also showed up in other lovecraft
stories after being trapped on the
planet yadath
carter eventually finds a way to use the
technology of the aliens who had trapped
him there to escape
slowly carter's plans went forward he
provided a lightwave envelope of
abnormal toughness
able to stand both the prodigious time
transition and the unexampled flight
through space
he tested all his calculations and set
forth his earthworm dreams
again and again bringing them as close
as possible
to 1928 he practiced suspended animation
with marvelous success
the short story at the mountains of
madness which lovecraft wrote in 1931
is also an example of a story with
science fiction elements
i've covered this story in its entirety
in this video here
the story is essentially about a group
of scientists who make an expedition to
antarctica
only to end up discovering a terrible
secret about humanity's past
in typical lovecraft fashion many of
them meet a terrible fate
without spoiling too much the story
involves the discovery of alien life
forms
and an impossibly ancient city that
predates all human civilization
this is one of my favorite ideas that
pops up in lovecraftian horror
inexplicably ancient structures of
unknown origin
this is certainly an idea that other
authors since lovecraft have adopted
one of them is dan simmons author of the
hyperion cantos
since we have been discussing the
hyperion books recently on this channel
it seems right to explore the ways in
which author dan simmons uses cosmic
horror
the galactic civilization which exists
in this series has explored thousands of
worlds
and on nine of them exist something
strange beyond all explanation
these nine worlds which i have also
discussed in a video here
are similar to each other in various
ways the main two being that they are
all earth-like
and the other being that beneath the
surface of each world
is an enormous system of labyrinths
dating back hundreds of thousands of
years
perhaps before humankind even existed in
its current evolutionary form
nothing exists to explain their
construction no leftover technology or
tools
no culture the civilization who had
built them known only as the builders
had vanished without a single trace
other than the labyrinths
george r.r martin borrowed countless
lovecraft names and themes for his
song of ice and fire book series he also
writes about an ancient race of people
known as the maze makers
like the builders from hyperion they
constructed vast labyrinths
they made from giant blocks of stone the
purpose of the mazes like in hyperion is
unknown
according to the legend the mazemakers
have been destroyed by a people from the
sea
this seems like a reference to the deep
ones of lovecraft's own lore
especially considering that they are
mentioned several times in the fourth
book in the song of ice and fire series
a feast for crows
now i know what you're saying a song of
ice and fire is fantasy not science
fiction
i get it but george martin has written a
lot of science fiction as well
and he's also gone on the record stating
that in his opinion there's not really a
difference between science fiction or
fantasy
and in fact many of the ideas that show
up in a song of ice and fire
also show up in science fiction story
that george r martin wrote decades ago
as i said in lovecraftian horror strange
ancient structures are a common concept
in general human beings can fall into
the trap of thinking that we mostly know
how the world works
we understand history we understand the
way in which the universe works
our histories tell us that civilization
began at a specific time
by creating a structure more ancient
than civilization and placing it
somewhere it was not meant to be
the author is creating a sense of
mystery and dread
the color out of space was published by
h.p lovecraft in 1927.
the story is narrated by a man from
boston this character is never given a
name
he is attempting to uncover the hidden
truth surrounding a place known
as blasted heath by the locals the place
was located near the hills
west of the town known as arkham
west of arkham the hills rise wild
and there are valleys with deep woods
that no axe has ever cut
there are dark narrow glinds where the
trees slow fantastically
and where thin brooklets trickle without
ever having caught the glint of sunlight
in the story during the summer of 1882
a meteorite crashed on the land of the
nahum family
the scientists which initially examined
the meteorite
found that it possessed strange
characteristics
they had uncovered what seemed to be the
side of a large
colored globule embedded in the
substance
the color which resembled some bands of
the meteor strange spectrum was almost
impossible to describe
and it was only by analogy that they
called it a color at all
the life form which appeared as this
color drained all the life from the
surrounding area where it had crashed
plants grew abnormally large but were
foul-tasting
the animals in the surrounding area
became deformed mutated
grotesque and the people in the area in
typical lovecraft fashion
were driven to madness in this story
lovecraft
creates a being that is truly alien to
us
it takes no humanoid form and has no
exact desires or intent
that we could discern speaking of a
color out of space
which was actually one of lovecraft's
personal favorites it was adapted into a
movie not too long ago
and some people really enjoyed it i
unfortunately did not
i don't think the movie was very good at
representing
the story or at representing the general
concepts in which lovecraft was trying
to get across
and the movie itself i found to be
pretty senseless
i would say that the film version of the
book annihilation is a much better story
which adapts the ideas presented
and lovecraft's the color out of space
interestingly enough when mentioning
science fiction authors people rarely
ever talk about lovecraft
i'm guilty of this as well i did an
entire video about the history of aliens
in science fiction
and didn't include any of his works i
think it's important to consider not
only the impact that his work has had
on the horror genre but on the science
fiction genre as well
now i've made several videos about
lovecraft on this channel you can check
them all out by clicking the lovecraft
link in the description
thank you guys so much for watching
peace out